[موسيقى]
على مدار التاريخ اعتقد كثيرون ان للقمر
ومنازله المختلفه تاثيرات غامضه على البشر
اليوم دراسه جديده تؤكد هذا الامر الاطباء
النفسيون في جامعه انزيانا وجدوا ان ظاهره
الانتحار تزداد خلال اكتمال القمر عادوا
الى سجلات طب الشرعي في مقاطعه ماريون في
انسيانا وراجعوا حالات الانتحار بين عامي
2012 و 2016
فوجدوا انها كانت تزداد بشكل كبير خلال
اسبوع اكتمال القمر
حتى الان لا يوجد تفسير علمي دقيق لهذه
العلاقه لكن العلماء يعتقدون ان زياده
الضوء المنبعث من البدر يمكن ان تكون
السبب في زياده حاله الانتحار خصوصا ان
الضوء المحيط يلعب دورا رئيسيا في ايقاع
الساعه البيولوجيه للجسم ما رايكم هل يؤثر
القمر على سلوكيات البشر
[موسيقى]